après le look surfeur voici venir le
look beachvolleyeurs depuis le début de
l'été le beach volley ou si vous
préférez le volley de plage envahi le
littoral c'est une discipline sportive
tout à fait sérieuse porté actuellement
par un véritable effet de mode
ce qui caractérise les estivales de
volley c'est la multitude de joueurs
ambiance décontractée pour un volley
ball en liberté des passionnés de toute
l'europe convergent vers les plages
bretonnes ont ce rendez vous sportif de
l'éthique phénomène c'est d'abord la
plage c'est le soleil comme aujourd'hui
et puis c'est le ciel bleu c'est les
jambes bronzées
c'est les gens en pleine forme donc
c'est tout l'aspect physique qu'on peut
avoir sur la pratique du volley ball et
c'est vrai que ce sont des athlètes qui
joue à haut niveau depuis 10 ans le
beach volley n'a cessé d'évoluer le 2 2
nous est venue des plages américaines de
californie du brésil le 3 3 est européen
aujourd'hui le volleyball de plage
connaît un succès extraordinaire c'est
devenu un véritable phénomène de mode il
plus en plus on voit des couleurs sur
les plages c'est très fluorescents les
ballons il ya encore dix ans et les
ballons tels que ce qu'on lui disait sur
place les ballons côté musée rap etc et
aigris qui était pas joli maintenant
tous les ballons sont colorés sont
fluorescents on voit vraiment une
on attache de plus en plus d'importance
à l'aspect visuel cyr a attiré l'oeil
le beach volley c'est ça en ce moment
c'est il faut attirer l'oeil sur la
plage
il faut montrer qu'on est en forme qu'on
hébron g on est habillé à la mode et
c'est ça le but vol le beach-volley
cesse la frappe de balle et coups de
soleil la recette est bonne ce week-end
les estivales étaient à binic et le
record de participation a été battu deux
cent cinquante trois équipes ont
participé au tournoi 1000 37 matchs ont
été disputés en trois jours